[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander Rose the
director of the long now foundation I'm
going to give you just a quick overview
of an event that's coming up I think you
all got little fliers in your hands but
we have some new additions to it it's
called the mechanic crawl and this the
idea for this event came to me as I
started taking the ferry into San
Francisco and riding my bike this way
and I realized that San Francisco has
some of the most amazing mechanical
treasures that nobody ever gets to see
and put together a little walk here
we're partnering up with the
Exploratorium as well as the the
maritime Parks Association the Jeremiah
O'Brien and the USS pampanito and the
museum mechanic it's all walkable
bikable we're gonna have secure bike
parking as well as car parking and the
museum Echenique if you haven't been
there it's down at Fisherman's Wharf it
has among other things Dan szalinski is
the second-generation owner and
proprietor there has been collecting
mechanicus
pretty much of the turn of the century
on forward including all the way up into
the 80s video games and that steam
powered motorcycle which is one of the
most amazing examples I'm going to see
if I can convince them to start it up
for the event the pampanito which is
actually the thing that started this up
is it has on board the most complex
mechanical computer ever built and it's
the targeting control computer for the
torpedo system and they have renovated
it to full working order and nobody
knows about it it's up in the conning
tower nobody ever gets to see it and
these wonderful world war two geeks have
made it completely work and nobody ever
gets to appreciate it so they're going
to be giving demos of that all day the
up on the Hyde Street Pier they're going
to have a Hicks diesel engine as well as
the old lighthouse for now lens assembly
running and the Jeremiah O'Brien if you
haven't seen it has a three
story tall steam engine that runs and
this is kind of the penultimate
steampunk item that very few San
Franciscans ever get to see go they're
gonna have it running all day and the
Exploratorium is going to have special
exhibits and docents including
explanations I'm hoping of the wave
organ if you haven't been out there it's
way out on the point and that's about it
if you're a lung now member you get free
you get in free if actually if you're a
member of any of these organizations you
get in free plus one and we're also
looking for more partners I'm trying to
get a contact with the San Francisco
Fire Department which has this amazing
pump station over here as well as their
fire boats if anybody knows any firemen
let me know and you can pick up your
tickets or order them through our
website at mechanic roll org or com we
also have tickets out front and we also
have fliers which you can give out to
your friends i'm kevin kelly of the long
now foundation welcome to the latest
monthly installment of the seminar on
long-term thinking just note that the
next one will be happening in june paul
ehrlich talking about long-term human
evolution
I'm normally stewart's up here but he's
nursing a kidney stone so we're gonna
swap positions and I'll be asking Iqbal
the questions and everyone can send
their questions down to two Stuart
so today's guest is Nick bar Kadir who
is coming from these coasts and one of
the things that we can look at in the
long now is long term two directories
and one of those long term ones is the
arc of development economic development
and Qadir and Iqbal HEC ball has a very
interesting perspective on this in part
because he's gone through the same arc
he grew up in Bangladesh still one of
the poorest undeveloped countries in the
world
and now today he
works in walks he began in Bangladesh
actually having to walk five or ten
miles to get medicines for his family
now he he walks in the corridors of
Harvard and he's currently the head of a
new center called the Ligon tum' Centre
for development at MIT and he's here to
talk about something that he discovered
I would say almost 15 years ago now
which is that the cellphone was a weapon
against poverty and at that time of
course nobody was paying attention to
cell phones because they were just cell
phones but now it's very clear that cell
phones are probably more than cell
phones they are probably going to be the
first ubiquitous technology of
communication on the planet they're kind
of the Esperanto of technology and so we
have this convergence of something that
will probably be the center of our
digital lives and and a weapon for
poverty and this of course is all just
the beginning because of other
technologies and so I'd like you to
welcome Iqbal who can explain the
details and the further aspects of his
vision of how we can use technology to
empower the poorest
[Applause]
good evening it's good to be here
beautiful day beautiful weather thanks
to the long now foundation Stewart Brand
who to invite me here and delighted to
be here and thanks Kevin for the kind
introduction I I think before I but let
me also mention that it's really special
privilege to be at the long now
foundation because I base my thinking on
not necessary I don't know how good I
would be at long-term thinking but I
base my solutions on long term
observations backward in the past and so
there are reflections on history and how
what that means for our problems today
so let me first take you for a minute to
Bangladesh where where I'm from and
where one of my projects really has
taken hold
which seems like this it's hard to
believe there's an economic revolution
taking place in Bangladesh but if you
look closely enough it's happiness I
lost article the entire villages are
being brought into the information age
[Applause]
well to start the story
I came to America 32 years ago to go to
college from Bangladesh and one of the
first thing I learned I mean while I was
doing research about what colleges to go
to and when I got here that not all
important colleges are in Washington DC
and and similarly because I came from
Bangladesh which had all the important
schools where in Dhaka its capital and
similarly
you know all important others kinds of
modern infrastructure like telephones or
electricity
most things we're in one capital city
and others just had little sprinkles of
things like in small towns but by and
large the concentration or
centralization of the country's economic
activities was very palpable in in a
poor country and big contrast with that
with the United States when I got here
and of course that has led me to think
about is there a connection between
centralization and stagnation and
dispersion or decentralization and
progress and the more I think about it I
find more and more connections and so
that's the underlying theme of my work
and to give you an of course you will
see that in most countries Bangladesh is
not unique at all in most poor countries
that is indeed the situation that you
have a one big mega city and large rural
areas that are neglected from a modern
infrastructure point of view but one
extreme example just to make the point
is you can see the two Korean you know
two Koreas and the North Korea South
Korea South Korea you can at least this
is just a picture of Electrical you know
electricity in the evening
and North Korea does have electricity
there's one town Pyongyang has
electricity but it's just there and
South Korea these these kind of
activities are all over all over the
country so this is an extreme example
but in most four countries you will see
again just to illustrate that most
quote-unquote economic activities are in
are in the hands of you are in one
central city and the rest of the country
is quite neglected now the reason I
think about it of course is because
Bangladesh is a poor country and I came
and from one of the poorest countries to
one of the richest countries and but at
the same time Bangladesh frankly wasn't
always poor talking about long term
think observation about 250 years ago
this is a book written by an American
writer and talking about how Bangladesh
was actually quite well-off 250 years
ago so in not just in agriculture but
also in manufacturing in terms of
fabrics now if that's the case I'd like
to think why countries go down and why
how they go up and is there a connection
between centralization and
decentralization and if there is we can
think about how to decentralize them and
but you know one many people will tell
you that all it depends on the culture
on the leadership etc so one of the kind
of the countries of course in like
England which was the crucible of you
know modern democracy and modern
capitalism it's not true that they had
great leadership over the last thousand
years when we just give me a minute to
read this over the last thousand years
or so many kings and queens of England
have played their part in betrayals
Regicides plots treason trosset ease and
revolts there have been five pretenders
to the crown two of them Impostors for
Kings have been forcibly deposed all
were subsequently murdered one of them
was publicly executed and actually it
goes on and on the the third world
countries of today we know have massive
problems in their governance but frankly
I I don't think they are much worse off
than this but so the question is what is
it that's preventing them what is it
that led despite this kind of leadership
in England things Cheng's changed how
did it become an exemplary country in
terms of progress and but then let's go
back to the contemporary situation of
the method we have for economic
development in poor countries the bridge
countries send aid to poor countries and
by and large this hasn't worked and
there are lots of evidences of that
including the worldwide poverty in poor
countries the one
in evidence I brought here is a book
called the elusive quest for growth this
book is written by someone who worked in
the World Bank for about 20 years and he
finds the grow economic growth that he
finds that illusive means it's hard I
mean I mean he's mystified how come it's
not happening and the question is why is
it failed and to me frankly it's not
that illusive it's quite clear so I want
to throw that perspective to you and see
if it makes sense one way to look at it
is look at the countries that have
developed from let's say over the last
1000 years I really feel good about
bringing this up because this is the
foundation of long-term thinking I'm at
least we can base our observation on on
the long-term observations now so in in
medieval England for instance or in
Europe people the economy started to
perk up because individuals were getting
empowered through new innovations
technologies this is just a picture of a
wheeled plow that new metals allowed
that were able they were able to plow
better in more place all that Northern
Europe had before that the southern
Europe was better in agriculture than
Northern Europe so this was but there
are many other things like eyeglasses
windmills water mills all sorts of
things that empowered citizens and what
they did is and this book will confirm
that the citizens got empowered from
below and they were able to demand
better checks and checks and balances
from the authorities so there was a
devolution of authority and there was an
evolution of empowerment through various
technological innovations and so there
was a better bargaining and that's how
we increasingly developed a you know
better checks and balances democracies
and capitalism etcetera you know emerge
from below
and so if you look at that and again we
can go into the details through
questions or other on other occasions
but by and large this this picture is
true our you know discussed in many
books including this one by David Landis
who taught at Harvard for 40 years now
if you believe if you see that then you
can see what has happened to giving aid
to poor countries governments that has
done just opposite it has empowered
authorities and consequently
marginalized citizens so if citizens
were ever to come to demands checks and
balances from their authorities they
were more and more ignored because the
authorities had other resources so if
you but I can summarize this actually
what about President Woodrow Wilson said
the history of Liberty is the history of
limitation a government's power not the
increase of it the American system is
based on checks and balances and
including limitations on the federal
government but yet the aid the rich
countries sent to poor countries
actually empower their their authorities
and that's why you see a major gap
between citizens and authorities on one
way or another it centralizes power
where decentralization is the key now
let me show it give you one specific
example the English Parliament started
out in the 13th century as a tax
legitimizing device the King wanted to
collect taxes and by that by that time
actually for another you know weaknesses
of the government of the King and
empowerment of citizens property rights
have come to be established and under
those circumstances when the king
started to collect you know as for taxes
people said or nobles or whoever said oh
you cannot take our or take taxes from
us because we have property rights
that's like seizing my property so if
you want to taxes you have to get our
consent now if you want consent in a non
democratic country how do you do that
well one
think that the King devised we called a
workshop called it the Parliament and
said you know we'll consult you will
consult with you some key people from
the country came to this workshop and he
said I'm gonna text this way what do you
think and they would say go ahead and
then it would become somewhat legitimate
and people the king was able to collect
taxes now as the economy is is you know
because of this empowerment's I talked
about people became more productive
people's wages go went up or they had
other things to do you know more
activities to pursue so then it was also
more expensive for the King to hire
bureaucrats or soldiers whatever so as a
result the King needed more money so
when he needed more money he had to come
to the Parliament and ask for a consent
slowly the consultation became a consent
giving mechanism and over time the
Parliament and each time the king came
to the Parliament the Parliament
demanded a deal they're all free that
port reduced that tariffs etc and that's
how what gave rise to new liberties that
the people of England did not have and
the king was constantly making
compromises because he needed money so
the point is the democracy emerged
through the economic clout of citizens
plain and simple and actually many many
deals were blunt deals economic money
deals between the Parliament and the
king so the question is what what helped
England was Kings shortage of money not
its adequacy what if there were foreign
aid to the king what would will happen
to England in terms of democracy and
capitalism the compromises that gave
rise to those things would not have been
made but at least slowed down so when
you give when we see aid to governments
in poor countries you can imagine what
damages they can be doing so governments
become responsive to citizens when
citizens make economic contributions to
governments as simple as that
and but let me show you one more thing
from this book
the subtitle of this book says
economists adventures and misadventures
in the tropics now misadventures a
little too much let's just think about
adventures
can you imagine writing a book that says
elusive let's say doctor writing a book
saying elusive quest for help that you
know he's having a quest for health and
cannot find healthy you know solutions
to his patients how would you be able to
sell that book and imagine the doctors
saying doctors adventures in human
helped forget about misadventures well
how come we and the doctors cannot get
away with such a book but these
economies do there's an important reason
I'm bringing this up not to make fun of
economies they the reason is the nature
of poverty is different from health care
in this country if the doctors are
having adventures the patients can speak
up but in the case of poverty we can set
you know economies loose but the
patients cannot speak up as a result
their adventures go on and this country
is stagnant and they're empowered by aid
and then they come and give their you
know give their theories and it doesn't
they don't work and this is why it's
important to make long-term observations
in our past and see what prob what how
we achieve progress and how we stagnated
so the story of progress is the story of
dispersion of power and that's really my
team in a and that's how I will describe
to you so in the early 90s I started a
you know I were her budding investment
banking career and that's where I
discovered a decentralizing force named
Moore's Law Gordon Moore one of the
founders of Intel observed in mid-60s
that every 18 months microchips the
brain of the computers go down in price
in by 50 percent right here in the Bay
Area now he
that means every three years namely
twice the time of eighteen months every
three years prices fall to by 75% to
one-quarter which means every six years
it becomes 1/16
so every 12 years it becomes one over
256 and you add another three years
let's say every 15 years it becomes
1,000 little bit more than a thousand to
$1 so the microchips were actually
marching to the poor people and it's
also potentially a decentralizing force
okay but III didn't know how to make use
of computers in countries where there is
a lot of illiteracy and so therefore
people couldn't quite use computers even
if they become they're becoming cheaper
and you know perhaps they could be
utilized but I didn't know how to use it
because computers are mostly made made
for literate people now one day in 1993
I had you know our I was working with
three or four people and our computer
network was connect was connected and we
were more productive we didn't have to
exchange floppy discs maybe many of you
don't know fallibilities
it used to exist and we and we could
update each other more frequently but
one time it broke down and I this is not
my picture this is what we found in the
computer and but one time when the
computer broke the network broke down I
was waiting for someone to come and fix
it and during that time I remembered
another day in 1971 when Bangladesh was
undergoing a war this is the Bangladesh
used to be called East Pakistan before
1971 and the you know the two can two
wings of old Pakistan was separating and
so there was a civil war there were a
lot of violence in the urban areas why I
lived in a city but I moved to a rural
area with my parents when my family
where there was a quiet place because
there was really no modern
infrastructure to even bring the you
know the the skirmishes into this
village and one time my mother asked me
to get some medicine for a younger
sibling some ten kilometers away so I
walked all morning to get there and when
I got there the medicine man wasn't
there so I walked all afternoon back and
so I remember this unproductive day
while I was having another one in New
York and I suddenly I put these two
unproductive days side by side and I
realized the connectivity is
productivity and so any it's true for a
modern office and also for any place
around the developed village because you
know I could have gotten more done if I
could tell I mean I was just a kid
thirteen years old but perhaps if
productive person would have been would
have done something if I was a fisherman
I could have fished that day then
wasting the day in just connecting with
somebody okay
and of course you can think about how
many you know let's say if the country
has today the country 150 million people
if you waste one day per month you'll
see millions of man months wasted in in
not having some kind of connectivity so
I started looking where did Bangladesh
lie in telecommunications of course
there was a centralization problem there
were one phone for every 500 people and
all most of those phones 70% of them
were in one city another city had 20%
and the remaining 10% in just in other
smaller towns so again it's a
concentration of the available
facilities so I started looking what can
be done about this and indeed I felt
connectivity is productivity but is it
so have other thinkers doers felt that
way so I couldn't quite find anything
but I did find this graph which is
produced by International
Telecommunications Union which is the
United Nations of telecommunications and
in the vertical axis it says
contribution to one new phone
to the country the GDP to the GDP of the
country and on the horizontal axis you
place your country so the highest GDP
country that can be accommodate to this
chart is $20,000 part per capita but the
United States will be way out outside
that but if you have a poor country
let's say $300 per capita GDP GDP is the
gross domestic product and for
annualized basis now if you have a $300
GDP country then you can see the impact
is five six thousand dollars okay so the
tremendous impact the poor of the
country you have bigger the impact which
I was quite interesting and I didn't
know exactly how but perhaps because
there is a greater amount of
inefficiencies a telephone can remove
but also I and of course this does not
capture the Moore's law was talking
about because it doesn't talk about the
cost of bringing in telephone so I asked
how much does it cost to bring in a
telephone let's say in Bangladesh and
despite all our inefficiencies because
if we had a state-led state-owned
company providing telephones it cost two
thousand dollars per phone so if you but
if it's two thousand dollars and it
lasts for let's say ten years then that
means this according to this curve the
country would be better would be making
fifty thousand dollars five thousand
dollars times ten but if it cost two
thousand dollars then it's a huge
benefit for two thousand dollar
investment $50,000 output but then if
the Moore's Law is right then this cost
of instead of two thousand dollar goes
to two hundred dollars or something even
smaller then the impact is even more
dramatic and it might be possible for me
to bring about telephones in some you
know easier way than it has been in the
past but let me just run by another
thinking I underwent one the Adam Smith
said a specialization leads productivity
but how would you specialize namely
let's say if I'm a fisherman and farmer
Kevin is a fisherman and farmer how are
we going to suddenly become I've been
becoming
fishermen and heaven is becoming a
farmer not until we can connect with
each other because we must be first be
able to depend on each other to be able
to rely on his goods and exchange with
my goods and in order to rely on each
other we must depend we must connect
with each other so if we are neighbors
of course we can sort of depend on each
other because we connect regularly but
then we cannot be the economy is very
very small just on small neighborhoods
so if you must expand your economy and
specialize more you must connect in some
other ways through a highway through a
river and but perhaps through a
telephone line but the key point is that
you must connect first in order to
depend on each other and then be able to
specialize and advance the economy in
general so I was pretty sure that this
could be done at this this makes sense
but the more these bureaucrats and other
important experts I met more they were
trying to Deakin Vince me that that's
you know it's not right thinking so I
want to go through a little bit about
what I went through so for example
nonsense number one poor countries are
under-resourced I don't think so for
example time time is a very important
resource the I was wasting time that's
an important resource the country is
wasting okay so while everybody tells me
the poor countries are poor because they
don't have resources the interesting
tragedy is the poor countries are poor
because whatever resources that do have
they waste them time is one of them
another is people so for instance if I
am a person in Bangladesh in order to do
anything productive I need to connect
with other people so if I'm trying to
connect with them otherwise I cannot use
my fellow countrymen so if I want to
connect with them that's another
important resource and there are many
many others that are wasted so the poor
countries are extremely wasteful
nonsense number two poor people lack
buying power why why do we worry about
that if this is a productivity tool then
it will make me produce more unable to
pay for it
so for instance in the United States we
buy a car putting a little bit of money
down
then we take a loan the car you know I
take a car home the car takes me to work
the work pays me a salary and then the
salary allows me to pay for the car so
the car actually pays for itself it's
because it's a Productivity tool so if
your telephone is a productivity tool we
shouldn't worry so much about is it's
the existing buying power we should
worry about whether they are going to
make us productive or not okay
nonsense number three you need to start
with money to make money okay fine
jag you were to put little money down to
get it for him to get a well let's say a
car but again if we have a shared access
then that can be broken down into you
know smaller pieces in fact telephone
started out in the United States as a
community based device nonsense number
four for example inability to meet
primaries people were telling me there's
shortage of food there's a shortage of
clothing shelter medicine whatnot but
again these are like the top down Big
Brother thinking why do we worry about
that income is the ability if people
have better income they can use their
brains by the way these brains are
another important resource that are
wasted okay because they're not utilized
somebody is trying to make a decision
for everybody okay and so that too is a
resource that needs to be put to use and
that brain gets activated when it
produces more when it's income is higher
to the owner of the brain so again
income is the ability it's not the
inability of having other needs because
they can buy food medicine and whatever
but the problem the real problem of
course these things we can sort out in
our heads but the real problem there was
some must be some other real problem on
the ground and I felt centralization was
the problem namely because there is one
city which had all the infrastructure
electricity and banks and whatnot if we
try to take the phones even if Moore's
Law and other says that it'll become
cheaper and cheaper you can take it all
over the country there is very little
other infrastructure to take it to there
that's the real problem centralization
stood in my way so for instance if you
want credit checks the ecology is not
there and there is no service that tell
me who would be a good subscriber who
would not be there are few banks through
which customers could pay bills the
contact points these things are lacking
and of course it was obvious to me that
you need one thing to get another new
thing on the ground so for instance the
internet was booming in this country at
that time
early 90s and that's because people
already had computers they had modems
they had telephone lines they had other
things on which a new idea can spread
quickly but that's the real problem in a
poor country where the other
infrastructures have not been built
partly because of the centralization
problem we talk I'm talking about now
let's say then I noticed these
microcredit organizations there are
there were several one was Grameen Bank
which has recently received a Nobel
Peace Prize and there was another
organization called brac there's another
one ASSA but anyway I started focusing
on Grameen Bank and basically these
banks give loans to poor people and they
created branches all over the rural
areas and so Grameen Bank had about a
thousand branches this is talking about
in 1993 and each you know the Grameen
Bank had two to three million borrowers
at the time and excellent repayment
records and most of their borrowers were
women and that's because over time they
found that women managed money better
and so I started looking at and I first
went to them and said you know perhaps
you could be my client okay because they
need to manage these branches but they
were not that interested because after
all this was a country without telephone
so they evolved in a decentralized way
that branches manage their accounts and
every week or so they reported to the
headquarters so if you go into the
headquarters it's relatively quiet place
even though they had two to three
million borrowers at the time so I
started focusing what is it that they do
what's the core
or activity and this is really the
simple model that a woman borrows money
from the bank then she buys you know
let's say a cow the cow gives milk she
sells the milk to her fellow you know
villagers and pays off the loan and
after a year or so she owns the cow of
course there were duck loans
chicken loans goat loans but the car was
most typical and then I realized that
you know a cell phone could be a cow too
because somebody could borrow some money
if there is a network out there then the
she could you know that would be a phone
for the whole community basically and
it's a business for her so I went back
to the Grameen Bank leadership and told
him that you know I think the cell phone
can be account and they said yeah that's
little logical but little crazy but
nonetheless somewhat logical so they
said they basically encouraged me to
pursue this idea but it was clear that
they couldn't fund the development of
the idea any further but they wanted to
cooperate with me if I could so I came
back to America and I convinced an angel
funder in New York his name is Joshua
mailman to give me $125,000 and we
created a company called Ghana phone in
Ghana phone and Bengali
it's an American company but in Bengali
it means phones for the masses this was
little daring in those days because 1 or
2 percent Americans had cell phones in
93 94 this is by this time it's 94 but I
believed in the Moore's law and I felt
it's going to become cheaper and cheaper
because the phones were become digitized
so but then again this is a long story
and of course I had many many rejections
from so that money allowed me to fly
around the world and try to convince
some telephone company to get into this
business and I felt once the telephone
company comes into the picture then
Grameen Bank would also commit because
they were encouraging me but not quite
committed so again I will spare you the
details but
I had maybe million miles in in frequent
flyers programs
I had many sleepless night and minor
loss of hair but I did eventually
convinced a the Norwegian telephone
company to join this consortium so this
is called Telenor Telenor basic the
basic structure is the Telenor provided
the know-how and Grameen family would
provide the distribution network in the
rural areas and then we of course
applied for a license from the
government and Grameen's good reputation
and Telenor s good reputation allowed us
to obtain a license from the government
and so that was by that time it was 1996
so it's about four years when I since I
started at the end of 96 so early 97 we
started providing a service and Ghana
phone had American shareholders from
here and was also a shareholder I mean
in 2004 we sold out those shares to
Telenor and Grameen and then but
basically we started with equity and
started building the network and we also
obtained a loan from the private sector
arm of the World Bank International
Finance Corporation but total initial
funding was about 120 million dollars
and so this is a coverage of Bangladesh
as of 2005 you can see its
telecommunications has become
decentralized all over the country and
by now by the way from internally
generated cash the company has invested
2 billion dollars so it has pretty good
network all over Bangladesh a country
that often does not have electricity in
many places ok but it has a pretty good
telecommunication coverage in mobile
modern totally digital GSM system and
but the the qaol model I talked about
there are 250 thousand entrepreneurs who
retail telephone services in the
villages in Bangladesh and they make a
living and they are also being upgraded
because the telephones are spreading so
much there eventually it's eating into
their business
and people are better connected and they
are born productive we can always talk
about these special cases now
Grameenphone
basic financials that they have about 25
million subscribers right now and the
country has 40 million telephones today
and that's more than hundred times the
number of phones that had that we had in
the country in 1994 and they come in
2006 the net profit of the company was
250 million dollars and it contributed
300 million dollars to the government in
taxes customs duties fees license fees
etc but here's the lessons from
Grameenphone that basically you'll hear
the government's need to provide
economically viable services well
private companies can provide them
governments must subsidize companies to
serve the poor or sometimes they say Oh
private companies don't do it government
must do it but company not only
companies can do it like I come in from
demonstrates but also companies can pay
taxes to the government poor countries
need aid businesses raise resources far
more than aid I can show you through
that curve from the ITU that the GDP
that has gone up in due to the telev
telephones distributed throughout the
country is much larger than the aid
received and also the economic
improvement is is dispersed not
concentrated in the hands of the few
rich countries either help or exploit
poor countries well both rich and poor
countries can gain by making people more
productive in fact it's not just
Norwegian telephone company or Norway
helping Bangladesh Bangladesh is helping
Norway and Bangladesh is a country of
150 million people Norway is a four and
a half million people country we should
be helping them
poor people are recipients well they are
a resource in fact the other wisdom I
hear that services cost too much for the
poor their involvement reduces the cause
the uneducated poor cannot do much well
they're eager learners because the
learning makes a difference in their
lives then you learn quickly I don't
learn a lot of things because I don't
have to like for example if you just use
Microsoft Word you don't necessarily
learn all the features you just get by
with whatever works for you but
something that improves your life you do
learn and so I find the poor people of
very good learners and you can make
money or you can only make money from
the poor no you can make money with the
poor because that's how there could be a
properly aligned approach that they make
money and your investment also makes
money let me quickly cover on this new
energy project we have which we have
tested a little bit but we are also
going Gehring up for a bigger test soon
again energy production started out in a
decentralized way in Europe and helping
democratic forces to emerge in Europe
because now if you have a lot of little
entrepreneurs producing one kilowatt
then one big businessman or a state this
produces 500 megawatts obviously it is
concentrated that hurts the potential
Democratic fabric of the country
so again Bangladesh centralization of
electricity today 67 percent of the
electricity produced is for one central
and metropolitan area but here is the
opportunity that's emerging before that
let me show you this picture taken from
Scientific American by Emeril ovens that
electricity today in the large
centralized power plants here in the
United States the field that you burn
ultimately you use only about 10 percent
at the other end where it's actually
utilized this is extremely wasteful so
the most efficient plant the combined
cycle actually throws away only 50% of
the fuel heat out into the air the more
inefficient one
actually throws away 70% but so at the
end of the many many you know transition
you lose some in transmission of the
electricity and then it goes out voltage
up and down whatever and you eventually
convert to the electricity the energy
you need by the way we don't we don't
consume electricity we consume light
sound heat these sort of things
electricity will produce only because
they're easy to transfer and easy to
manipulate perhaps okay
but we at the end of the day the energy
we use is very little and as a result
electricity production in large power
plants is the biggest culprit of
greenhouse gases okay so if on the other
hand this is a decentralized energy
productions that is reimbursing in the
Western countries this one is called
micro CHP which is CHP is combined heat
and power because if you produce
electricity in a in a let's say in a
very nice through a very nice engine
that is quiet and doesn't need very much
maintenance produce it at your home
because you have a gas supply or
something then the heat that comes out
that you do otherwise throw away in a
central fan you could use it up to warm
up your house so with that actually the
heat utilize the energy utilization goes
up to 80 percent and so that's a much
better it way of reducing carbon
emission and so this is in beginning to
you know gain traction in Europe and and
Japan and perhaps in the United States
so this I feel also gives rise to a
possibility that we could use this
decentralized for our production for
small entrepreneurs in developing
countries so here is the example and we
are using the the engine to use the heat
to dehydrate fruits and vegetable which
is a very very healthy approach and
because otherwise you know cooking food
for example I learned this from our
partner in dehydration whitney work ad
he was still teaching me that the that
dehydration actually preserves enzymes
and when you're cooking you might be
destroying
the enzymes for instance so dehydration
is a very good thing that in in a poor
country people can dehydrate herbs
medicine medicinal plants fruits and
vegetables and lift up their economies
because you can produce a lot more
valuable things than what you consume
locally
okay so and so because these countries
are tropical countries they don't need
to warm up their houses so and the light
of course could give rise to education
and other activities in the evening so I
tested this in two villages in
Bangladesh in 2005 and we are gearing up
for a larger test in from this fall and
again to summarize both cellphones and
micro CAHPS help poor people capitalize
on the global economy because the global
R&D are behind this kind of products
okay and that's a great deal of value
that's a great deal of aid that the rich
countries can actually send to poor
countries and that can put them on the
global economic highway too so people in
the West I think can make tools that can
ignite the economic brushfire and poor
communities will be allowed to build up
their own prosperity I think that's the
basic way I could summarize our my
activities here and again based on that
philosophy we have recently established
a Center at MIT with a 50 million dollar
gift from the leg artem global capital
global development to promote bottom-up
entrepreneurial development in poor
countries and thank you very much
so questions a reminder sent him to
people in the yellow hats and we'll pass
them up here okay well um that seems to
work wonderfully in Bangladesh are you
finding that the same decentralization
process with cell phones works in all
the other developing countries of the
world I think so
because see in Bangladesh was lucky to
have excellent microcredit organizations
and that's why I planned through
microcredit actually see the project was
based on three observations one is that
the Moore's law is making things cheaper
and cheaper on the supply side and the
demand side indeed that connectivity is
a very useful thing and people become
more productive and they can pay for it
the third element was the microcredit
organization now what's happening is
that since then another technology has
emerged namely prepaid cards okay which
is allowing the first two premises are
still true that's why in Africa today
there are I think there are six times as
many cell phones than fixed phones in
Africa because of those two first
premises are still true and they are
getting decentralized yes what country
would you say is sort of been most
impacted in the same model
besides Bangladesh I think Nigeria is an
example
gone are many African countries by the
way one of the most interesting thing is
that the countries where even
governments are not functioning like
Afghanistan Iraq and Somalia and other
places cell phones are very very useful
which is kind of interested to Congo
okay
that's because when you don't have a
system to protect you
you increasingly demand depend on your
friends and relatives and then you even
need the phone even more this is a
question from Lex
Ian is he or she here okay there you
have cell phones in Bangladesh remained
shared resources or how they become
status symbols that is have the nature
Bangladesh culture changed by the
introduction of cell phones if so how I
first of all it's not a status symbol
anymore because there are 40 million
phones and it's a large country still we
have one let's say 150 million people so
one out of four people have it phone so
it's a it's not a status symbol anymore
but the culture has changed because I
think people are connecting better with
we you know because we had very poor
infrastructure in the country we used to
think we had a bigger country because
it's hard to connect from one place to
another but I think now we realize that
our country is actually pretty small and
people are connecting with each other
and they are getting more things done
this I can assure you yeah okay this is
a question from Paul Linda Linda don't
okay there you go if connectivity is
productivity as you suggest are barriers
of language and culture impeding
progress worldwide sure but again there
are you know productivity is not
everything in life but the point is is
indeed if you cannot connect with
languages if you cannot speak in a
language which is probably one of the
first technologies for for connectivity
okay but of course but at the same time
whenever we do connect we we produce we
we can produce more because there's a
mutual cooperation okay but then again
you know we can always have I'm not
proposing that we eliminate all
languages that have one no but it's it's
certainly each language has its own
beauty but we need to connect that's a
more generic concept than whether we
need to have it through any other I'm
not arguing on what's the form of the
connectivity yes so I'm curious
personally whether you've returned to
that village where you were having that
really bad unproductive day and looked
at the changes in the village that we
have been brought about by the
revolution that you serve instigated or
you have any second thoughts about the
changes that you would have seen there
no I have seen I actually have been to
the village okay and I have seen many
people who care
phones with them now and indeed I've
seen the place the lady who sells these
services in that village okay and the
what all I can say is that there is
there is more connections between you
know people actually by the way don't
necessarily use the phones from village
to village but they're connected with
the urban centers more so because they
supply fruits and vegetables chicken
into the towns and the people are
trading with the town so that kind of
activities has certainly changed a lot
in fact I let me give you one example do
you have some time yes you have a funny
time we I met this doctor recently in
Dhaka he said our phones are making him
pretty rich I said well how is this how
is that and he said because he is he his
ancestors had some land in the rural
areas that was completely unused and
left abandoned so since the cellphones
have come about he can visit his village
and he created a fish farm okay but
because while he goes there every
weekend he's still connected to his
other activities in the urban centers so
interesting thing is that it has brought
investment into the village because this
person remains connected while he's
visiting this investment yeah there's a
question from John Markoff can the
Grameen phones become internet devices
and therefore extend the original wealth
wealth creation model definitely
actually one thing we have to remember
that although I the the Moore's law I
was talking about and initially I
thought computers could not be you know
wouldn't be that useful because people
are not literate I mean large illiteracy
rate but interestingly of course the
phones are computers and so increasingly
the you know if we now have in
Bangladesh one way to look at it is that
we have 40 million computers that are
connected okay so in fact we already can
provide on the internet on the cell
phone network you can connect
your computers okay and receive Internet
services but on top of that the cell
phones themselves will are able to soon
be able to see you know have some of the
internet services yes of course so one
of the in your diagram one of the things
that you were suggesting was that when
you had this decentralized power that
that was a source of democracy so this
is a question from Chris Jeffries you
raise your hand there what is the state
of democracy in Bangladesh today and how
have cellphones changed them see this is
this is a long term this is a long term
foundation so I think I think the impact
is has to be seen in the long term but I
can tell you that the overall
connectivity of people increases their
ability to organize themselves okay but
perhaps not documented in Bangladesh but
there are many countries in which cell
phones you utility in the political
arena okay is well documented in
including in the Philippines Joseph
Estrada
excuse me perhaps in the US yes Joseph
Estrada in the Philippines people send
text messages to organize their protests
against a dictator in the Philippines
there are many others the recent
problems in in Burma okay they were they
were partially you know problem means
they had demonstrations around that
there there's generally people you know
remember again this is why there's so
much to learn from the history the
long-term observations of the first
world the you know what happened when
writing became right of printing became
easily available 500 years ago okay
people connected more it was hard to put
down the lid on people when they started
to learn they read their own Bible etc
okay so technology is constantly
shifting power and changing the
political system and so it sometimes
it's not perceptible immediately but
it's certainly happening
is there anything that you worry about
that this the role cellphones in this
development cycle I think every
technology could be abused so therefore
one could worry about it but the
benefits are much larger than the than
the worries okay so for instance I when
I was in the company I had left quite a
few years ago now we when the police
came and said some criminal is using the
phone okay but the criminality is not
necessarily fault of the phone because
the criminal is using Bengali language
how can we turn off that language okay
or he eats rice can we turn off rice no
the criminals are empowered by whatever
they have do we need to stop the crime
but the the police is also empowered
just to make my second point because the
cell phones were able to locate people
okay and you know identify the cell
where the person might be using the
phone so usually yes there are some
quote/unquote superficial observations
about how these things might be hurting
us okay
but at the end of the day the overall
gain is much bigger this is a question
from Paul with all the polls raise our
hands says Paul what are some other
areas of technologies that need micro
financial help saying that is are there
other technologies that could be spread
by microfinance that's hard to tell but
there are a lot of things that
organizations like Grameen Bank and brac
and other microfinance organizations are
promoting for example Grameen Bank has a
large program to install solar panels in
people's houses so that gives them some
electricity so there are quite a few the
point is to find an income-generating
technology that could actually our
Grameen Phone might be its first one
okay but the model is now established
and anything that generates income could
be financed
through micro loans or any loans there
is other certain technologies that
microfinance would not work with well if
you have microfinance has a you know I
think the the point is how much benefit
can you get out of it and that could be
sold does and that could be sold in the
community that whether that corresponds
to the capital cost okay
so if there is a viable business let's
say it's caused $20,000 which is much
much larger than these things but if you
have let's say it's producing revenues
of $1,000 then even if not Michael
microcredit even a banks would lend it
for for that so I think it depends not
on the technology but whether the
benefits could be what is that monetized
okay monetized
and that correctly corresponds that can
sustain the capital cost that's really
the real issue but in this case it did
and that's why I did pretty well yeah
for Matt Grimes
raise your hand if you're still here
okay is there any hope for applying such
a populist empowering approach in
countries hostile to both external
influence and decentralization such as
North Korea and Myanmar yes in general
of course you need the government's
cooperation to start a service okay for
example in Cuba recently the government
used cell phones allowed the use of cell
phones and it wasn't allowed until very
recently I think the government people
could use it but in the general
population couldn't but only two weeks
ago Raul Castro allowed this to three
weeks ago okay so but the point is is
yes in general you always need the
permission of the government but the
interesting thing is that so we always
think governments can allow certain
technologies or not but I think that's a
limited way of looking at the issue the
a greater more interesting way of
looking at the issue is how technology
changes the government
okay because technology and by the way
in any country including here forget
about the government of any countries in
here we always have an incumbent
underestimates the potential of a new
technology so for instance the internet
was underestimated by AT&T that's why we
had a well which maybe many of us have
forgotten about but AOL or Google that
something came about right so similarly
IBM didn't imagine notice the potential
of personal computers so what I'm saying
is there's always the existing players
may underestimate a new innovation and
that is an interesting entry point for
the innovations because people
understand me so they let it enter but
then it emerges in a bigger way many
people get benefit from it and then it's
too too large to stop okay and by that
time this technology may have
transformed that society that has
happened right here and so it can happen
in that way in poor countries and this
is why the Internet in many countries
many poor countries were not necessarily
regulated it came by surprise and they
had to regulate it afterwards because it
was too fast and by that time things
were already transformed to some extent
yeah
so so you're obviously an optimist about
things and I'm wondering if you were
always an optimist as a little kid in
Bangladesh or whether you became an
optimist now I am an optimist because
it's it's a you know I think it's
interesting to solve problems so if if
we have problems I think all our
problems we have one way or other solve
through innovations so we may face other
problems then we have to think hard and
come up with a solution but if that
means I'm an optimist yes I am another
question from
here Michael Lynch okay what do you
think of the One Laptop Per child do you
think that this initiative is going to
be useful towards the goal of
decentralizing empowering the poor sure
but if the question is how do you
distribute it and I don't know Nikolas
has some plans Nicholas Negroponte who
started this project and the of course
it's wonderful to have tools to kids and
they can learn their brains get
activated etcetera but I'm detecting not
very much enthusiasm what why do you say
we know really I don't know my point is
I don't know how far it has actually
succeeded on the ground okay so III
think we need to think maybe how to
actually distribute them and would you
encourage the government of Bangladesh
to purchase them see I'm generally
trying to avoid the I don't want to
burden the government with that because
if it does then how does it distribute
there are many kids how many computers
can the government by if it has a few if
it buys a fewer number of computers than
the number of children then how would it
allocate them would it give it to its
favourite bureaucrats okay would it give
it to some favorite people see I think
it's much better to try through
entrepreneurial means what would your
suggestion be for making or making sure
that every kid in Bangladesh gets the
computer as soon as possible I think one
idea would be frankly is to have a you
know let's say a older kid let's say 16
year-old or 18 year old buy a computer
and have little kids play with it and
she collect he or she collects some
money from the from the parents of these
children renting it out yeah renting it
out or have a little playground where
everybody plays with this and then it
establishes business by the way one of
the interesting things and these are
established through actual data so for
example in India which is a democratic
state officially
the point is it's no there's nothing
wrong my point is the reason I'm saying
this is that the state supports the most
prestigious schools the Indian Institute
of Technology's for instance which
competes with MIT for instance but the
the interesting data is emerging that
the slums parents of slums like to send
their kids to private schools because
the private schools provide better
education why is this why are the slum
dwellers trying to send kids to private
schools and the state is supporting the
best schools
what is the reason the state must be
taking care of some people not others
people on which it depends it takes care
of them and that's the proof that the
the vast majorities of these countries
perhaps do not have enough voice and
that's why empowerment is necessary yeah
this is a question we've got more than
once there's no name on it but it's it's
just a tiny detail that some people are
perplexed by which is how are the
millions of cell phones charged in
remote places without electricity
through difficulty well sometimes people
have solar panels sometimes people take
their their phones to you know
neighboring towns and and also charge
car batteries to bring the car batteries
that serves them for a while and one
interesting thing I noticed through
trying to do the electricity project is
that we picked a village that didn't
have any electricity or there was no
prospect to get electricity there for a
while
and one surprising thing was that
village had ten televisions okay how
people take the trouble to take car
batteries to a nearby town charge it and
bring it and have little entertainment
so the point is people are trying to get
ahead as far as they could go it's the
public system that has failed that has
not provided the necessary sir
but people are doing all sorts of
difficult things to get it done yeah a
question from Ben
Tim Tim chime okay one impediment many
development economists have noted this
how risk-averse poor people are when
failure is catastrophic you get
conservative are they being proven wrong
by the criminal no in fact it is true
it's it's a human nature even in England
that I was talking about in medieval
time sometimes new innovations took long
time to take hold
simply because if the farmers I'm
talking about 10th century in England
okay if they produce too much the prices
would fall they would suffer if they
produce too little they would suffer
because there would be starvation
okay so people who are very risk-averse
and adopting new technology took quite a
while to adopt new innovations in in
those situations okay so yeah so but the
solution is to increase their income
because then they can take additional
risks what is your long-term vision for
the like entombment center will be
developing centres in emerging markets
or is this going to be just based in MIT
yeah we just started in September and we
are we provide fellowships to MIT
students who can think about new
possibilities of organic bottom-up
enterprise in developing countries using
innovations using their entrepreneurial
skills and so we will we we hope to
develop collaborations with universities
or other institutions in developing
countries so that we could this could be
a means of recruiting good students good
entrepreneurial talent or it could be a
means of our students learning from
those institutes the context the ground
realities of the problems and so yes we
would be in starting some kind of
operation with other universities for
instance or other research centers in in
developing countries and what would you
say that the biggest challenge that you
have for the center what what is the
thing that is keeping you up at night
well we are new so we don't know exactly
what is the how do we identify the real
entrepreneurial talent for instance okay
because there is really no set formula
for that okay and we said we are working
hard to find the criteria to identify
the students who will be good fellows
and this this year we elect we selected
12 of them and and we'll ramp up and of
course we think we are doing right
things to encourage them to go back to
developing countries but there is always
that risk that they might come here and
be lured away in a good job in the
United States however because we are
they're meant to be entrepreneurs they
might they can make more money
potentially even in going back to their
countries so it may not be the
old-fashioned problem of somebody came
to be a bureaucrat and then he simply
joins an investment bank in this country
so hopefully we'll do fine you talked
about the misguided notion of the large
development money and age aid agencies
funding Authority rather than the
decentralized empowerment obviously if
there is money to be used to help
developing countries develop do you have
serve a large scale model of how you
think that money should be used is it I
mean besides giving the Legatum Center
more money is there is there a mechanism
that you see that could absorb the the
the sort of good intention to money of
the world to develop the developing
countries well I was trying to show that
that giving money to the wrong side is
is exacerbating the problem okay so if
you cannot find the right side then just
don't give money okay but if you do find
the right side then you
find what what works there but
Grameenphone is a very good example of a
very large-scale project okay by now two
billion dollars have been invested but
there are many many possibilities out
there okay where you could fund an
entrepreneur and and then if it is a
good idea and he makes money it becomes
large-scale on its own it gets
replicated by other people so you don't
have to worry just find the right thing
to do
do you have practical suggestions about
places people should direct their own
giving I think if they there is always
you know if you want to give something
to somebody then try to identify a real
entrepreneur through organizations that
you might be able to be in touch with
you know there are always small NGOs and
other organizations in four countries
and that's one way to reach out to
individuals I think by the way rich
countries can always help poor countries
okay but it the real help is much better
if it's simply people to people so Bill
Gibson the science fiction writer
famously said that the universe that the
future has already arrived it's just
unevenly distributed are there places in
the developing countries even in the
slums of Bangladesh where the future has
arrived and they have something to teach
us about what will be coming well
innovations frankly can come from
anywhere okay and in a in a in a in if
we think about our global warming
problem here you know which is a global
problem but it's it's a problem we have
to admit is by and large created by the
rich countries because of the and of
course now India and China and others
are joining but the resource so-called
resource poor countries
okay are likely to innovate in ways that
minimizes the use of energy for instance
okay because we had plenty of energy we
have been
wasteful okay so those technologies or
those innovations are likely to help us
all yeah I think this there's more
questions that we really appreciate your
coming here and giving us the long-term
perspective on development and thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you